top prom isn't the most impressive ruin
in the world it's not even the most
impressive ruin in the neighborhood
Angkor Wat sits only a couple miles away
and it's the largest religious monument
ever built but top ROM is more human
scale and its merged with nature
once the humans left its original name
was Raja vihara the royal monastery and
was dedicated to the buddhist
personification of wisdom but it's a new
place now silk cotton trees and
strangler figs have merged with the
carved rocks to create new structures
the temple was built a thousand years
ago around 1186 just after Angkor Wat
during the Golden Age of the Khmer
Empire in what's now Cambodia the koomer
controlled most of Southeast Asia and
the capital city Angkor was the biggest
urban centre in the world before the
Industrial Revolution and they had
incredible technology to support such a
large congregation of humans Southeast
Asia gets heavy rainfall in one season
and a lot less in another
so the Khmer built water management
systems like huge reservoirs canals
channels and dikes that allowed them
three harvests a year it might have been
the best technology of the time and they
built these temples at their peak camera
Empire a ruler of Giovanna and the
seventh who also built a Corps tom
nearby is the man credited but a man's
name doesn't really capture the true
size of this project and then about two
or three hundred years later the society
collapsed it wasn't all at once or for
one reason but one reason archaeologists
and ecologists hypothesized was that
environmental factors otherwise known as
climate change overwhelmed those amazing
water management systems droughts and
then flood would have destroyed them
then a young PhD student named Marybeth
day spent about six years digging and
found evidence for this theory in the
form of sediment records in the
reservoir the ruling class abandoned
this place they moved south and then for
four or five hundred years the forests
merged with top rom until it was quote
rediscovered it's a beautiful place but
it's haunting what hundreds of thousands
of people would be living here if the
city had survived it should give us
pause our civilization is a
collaboration with nature a giant
structure must sway with the wind and
roll with the earthquakes or else it
will surely quietly fall Hollywood films
often depict the destruction of urban
centers the crisis comes at once either
in the form of a monster we can band
together and fight or as nature
unstoppable but in reality our biggest
cities have died before this one did it
just happens over a longer period of
time the rain falls the roots grow and
nature eats what we built the best
technology of that time wasn't enough
you